[Música]
los seres humanos fuimos creados con una
misión muy especial esto lo aprendí de
un maestro espiritual en medida que la
humanidad no es la primera ni la más
antigua ni la más importante de la
creación pero si tiene un propósito
esencial que es cuidar y proteger de
todas las formas y manifestaciones de
vida que existen sobre nuestra sagrada
madre piel
esto no saben todas las culturas
ancestrales a lo largo y ancho del
planeta
pero nuestro nivel de individualismo y
competitividad ha hecho que nos
olvidemos de ese conocimiento y nos
desconectamos totalmente de nuestros
propios
el resultado de esta desconexión es la
generación de un modelo insostenible de
desarrollo que nos ha hecho responsables
de la más profunda crisis ambiental con
un impacto social económico y político
de todos los tiempos
qué acciones resultan claves entonces
para transformar nuestra conciencia y
acercarnos de nuevo a nuestros
principios ancestrales para empezar es
importante entender que es cuidar y cómo
generar una conciencia de cuidado
según el diccionario cuidar es
preocuparse por el bienestar y las
necesidades propias y de los demás es
preocuparse por nuestra salud mental
física y espiritual es dedicar tiempo de
calidad a nuestras familias ya nuestras
amistades escucharles apoyarles
entendernos es poder contribuir a su
felicidad y poder solventar sus
necesidades
es generar acciones colectivas que nos
lleven a cambiar un poquito este mundo
que nuestro vivir
incluida la protección de la naturaleza
de los animales y del medio ambiente
ahora generar conciencia del cuidado es
entender que esto es importante y
necesario para nuestro bienestar propio
y el de los demás esta conciencia es la
que hace que cuidar sea un voluntario
desinteresado que nazca del corazón y
que sólo así nos va a permitir
conectarnos con lo más profundo de
nuestro ser
con lo más profundo de los otros seis
desde la organización que yo formo parte
es una organización que trabaja
principalmente con comunidades rurales
hemos encontrado una forma de acercarnos
generando una conciencia del día
al trabajar con hombres y mujeres
debemos identificar cuántos tiempos
dedicar cada uno a sus labores diarias y
así analizar sus posiciones
cada persona debe reportar lo que
realiza cada hora del vídeo desde que se
levanta hasta que si puedes
al finalizar se organizan como con
mixtos
lo más evidente es que las mujeres
dedican mucho más tiempo a las labores
de cuidado que los hombres en un estudio
realizado por el dane y unas mujeres en
2020 se evidenció que las mujeres
dedican 7.1 horas diarias a labores de
cuidado no remuneradas en colombia en
comparación con los hombres que dedican
tres puntos dos horas diarias a este
tipo de trabajos
el otro resultado evidente es que ni los
hombres ni las mujeres dedican tiempo de
calidad para el cuidado propio y por
tanto descuidan su salud física mental y
espiritual
entonces como propiciamos este cuidado
propio y el de los demás
para ello se nos ocurre que es
supremamente fundamental poder realizar
un cambio en los estilos de crianza de
tal forma que desde muy pequeños los
niños y las niñas entiendan que las
labores del cuidado y no son exclusivas
de las mujeres sino que es algo que nos
corresponde a toda la comunidad
resulta que los niños cuando aprenden
esto desde muy pequeños se convierten en
adultos que son mucho más amorosos y
responsables y protectores con sus
familias se convierten en padres
presentes que se preocupan no sólo
cualquier bienestar económico sino
además por el bienestar emocional de los
hijos además se convierten en seres
mucho más solidarios con las causas
justas con las causas sociales y con el
cuidado de la protección de la
naturaleza y el mundial a su vez se ha
identificado que las mujeres al disponer
de mucho más tiempo pueden acercarse a
los procesos comunitarios formativos
recreativos
esto hace que las mujeres alcancen un
nivel de autonomía y un nivel de
independencia mucho más alto que nos
lleva a participar mucho más activamente
de las decisiones que se toman en la
comunidad
y esto es súper clave porque resulta que
las mujeres que participan a nivel de
espacios de toma de decisiones centran
sus iniciativas a partir de su relación
con las labores del cuidado entonces
mientras que para los hombres es muy
importante el acceso a las vías en los
territorios para las mujeres además que
es fundamental que existan medios de
transporte y transporte escolar para que
ellas y niños y las niñas no tengan que
caminar largos y peligrosos proyectos y
así evitar exponerse a todo tipo de
violencias
asimismo mientras que para los hombres
son fundamentales los proyectos para la
producción agrícola para las mujeres
familia es esencial los proyectos que
tienen que ver con la seguridad
alimentaria es decir la producción de
alimentos para el consumo vial
igualmente y los temas relacionados con
el agua
los hombres se enfocan muchísimo en el
saneamiento y el alcantarillado mientras
que para las mujeres es esencial también
la protección de los videos y los
incidentes de agua porque esa agua es la
que va a llegar a los hogares y es la
que van a utilizar para el consumo para
la preparación de alimentos para el
aceite por lo tanto para las mujeres es
supremamente fundamental que la salud y
la calidad de vida de sus familias
mejoren
además algo que también es muy
importante que se ha evidenciado es que
las mujeres que participan de procesos
comunitarios lo hacen en red
y eso hace que sea un trabajo
colaborativo muy alejado de los
liderazgos individuales cuando tanto
ellos se han comprometido y propenden
por la protección del territorio y las
comunidades y sus iniciativas entonces
van mucho más allá del bienestar
personal
así que si queremos contribuir a la
formación de hombres cuidadores y
mujeres cuidadoras con poder de decisión
y espacios comunitarios y generen
impacto sostenible en la sociedad
debemos lograr que las personas se
piensen primero desde el autocuidado y
desde el cuidado colectivo esto hace una
gran diferencia porque cuando estas
personas ejercen el liderazgo lo harán
pensando desde el poder para servir a
los demás y no desde el poder para pasar
por encima mismos
como podemos ver es posible por
encontrarnos con esa misión especial que
tenemos todos los hombres y todas las
mujeres si entendemos que el cuidado no
tiene gel que nos pertenece a todos como
responsables de este piano y de esta
humanidad
[Música]